♪♪
Tyra: PEOPLE THINK BEAUTY
IS SOMETHING YOU'RE BORN WITH,
NOT SOMETHING YOU CREATE.
HOW NAIVE.
♪♪
FIND OUT HOW THIS GROUP OF TEN
GOT DOWN TO THE FINAL THREE
WITH MOMENTS
YOU'VE NEVER SEEN BEFORE.
♪♪
YOU ACTUALLY THINK
THAT EVEN IF I WAS A LESBIAN,
I'D BE REMOTELY
ATTRACTED TO YOU?
YOU LOOK LIKE YOU'RE ABOUT
TO GO LIKE THIS.
WE BLACK, WE WOMEN?
I'M A LESBIAN,
SHE'S VOLUPTUOUS.
(BOTH SHOUTING)
- DROP IT LIKE IT'S HOT, BABY?
- MISTER JAY!
Tyra: AND STAY TUNED
FOR THE SECOND HOUR,
TO FIND OUT WHO WILL BE
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
♪ OH! ♪
♪ WANNA BE ON TOP? ♪
♪ NA-NA-NA-NA-NA ♪
♪ NA-NA-NA-NA-NA,
NA-NA-NA-NA-NA ♪
♪ WANNA BE ON TOP? ♪
Tyra:
IT ALL BEGAN A FEW MONTHS AGO,
WHEN WE STARTED A PROCESS
THAT WOULD CHANGE LIVES.
I WAS LOOKING
FOR AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
SO I LAUNCHED
A NATIONWIDE SEARCH
AND PEOPLE SENT TAPES IN
FROM ALL OVER THE COUNTRY.
RIGHT AWAY, I COULD SEE GIRLS
WITH POTENTIAL.
I WANT TO SHAKE THE DUST
OFF THIS SMALL TOWN.
'CAUSE I AM THE TRUE DIVA.
I COME HERE AND MORBIDLY
WRITE MY HORRIBLE POEMS.
WELL, EVERYBODY IS
SO SKINNY AND THIN.
I'VE GOT A LITTLE CURVES.
AND WHY I WANT
TO BE A SUPERMODEL,
IS BECAUSE I'VE ALWAYS WANTED
THE GLAMOROUS LIFE.
WITH MY EXOTIC LOOK,
GIRL-NEXT-DOOR LOOK...
MY NAME IS GISELLE SIMPSON
AND THIS IS MY MOM.
I DON'T CARE IF IT
WAS MISS SOYBEAN,
MISS BLUE GRASS
OR WHATEVER, MISS CHITLIN,
I WAS GOING TO ENTER IT, OKAY?
I WANT TO BE A SUPERMODEL
BECAUSE I DESERVE FAME
AND FORTUNE.
OPPORTUNITY IS KNOCKING ON MY
DOOR AND I'M GOING TO OPEN IT.
Tyra:
OUR TEN LUCKY FINALISTS WERE
BROUGHT OUT TO NEW YORK CITY,
WHERE THE REAL
COMPETITION BEGAN.
- HOW ARE YOU?
- WE LOVE YOU!
(SHRIEKING)
Tyra:
THE GIRLS WERE SHOWN
THEIR PENTHOUSE APARTMENT.
OH, MY GOSH!
GIRL, WHICH ROOM
WE GOING FIRST?
Tyra:
EACH ROOM WAS NAMED
FOR ONE OF THE FASHION
CAPITALS OF THE WORLD.
AND THE THREE CHRISTIAN GIRLS,
ROBIN, SHANNON AND KESSE
ROOMED TOGETHER IN MILAN.
WE'RE GOING TO NAME
OUR ROOM THE DIVA ROOM.
Elyse:
THE GIRLS IN MILAN SEEM TO BE,
JUST, ON THE OTHER
SIDE OF THE WORLD.
THE SEPARATION
BETWEEN THE TWO ROOMS
HAS A LOT TO DO WITH RELIGION.
I'M NOT INTERESTED IN HAVING
QUIET TIME TO READ THE BIBLE.
I AM A MILITANT ATHEIST.
WHEN I FOUND OUT
ELYSE WAS AN ATHEIST,
I HAD EXTREME RESERVATIONS
ABOUT HER.
I REALLY FEEL SORRY FOR HER.
ANYBODY HOME?
Tyra:
THE GIRLS HAD BARELY
STARTED TO UNPACK,
WHEN THEIR FIRST
SURPRISE VISITOR ARRIVED.
A PHYSICAL TRAINER,
ARMED WITH A SCALE.
WE'RE GOING TO DO A LITTLE TEST.
HEIGHT AND WEIGHT, TO SEE HOW
YOUR BODY WEIGHT CHANGES
OVER THE TIME THAT WE'RE
GOING TO BE TRAINING.
ELYSE, TERRIFIC.
THERE YOU GO, 114.
OH, MY GOSH.
Robin:
IF YOU'RE NATURALLY SKINNY,
YOU'RE NATURALLY SKINNY,
BUT WHEN YOU CAN COUNT
EVERY, YOU KNOW, VERTEBRAE,
THAT'S SICKLY.
Elyse:
I THINK FOR ROBIN,
IT MUST BE HARD,
BEING AMONG GIRLS
WHO ARE SO SKINNY.
OKAY, SO WE'RE GOING
TO TAKE OFF THREE POUNDS,
SO GIVE ME JUST, LIKE A,
YOU KNOW WHAT I'M SAYING?
OKAY, SO WE'LL GO WITH 165.
YEAH, WE WEIGH 165.
Tyra:
THE SECOND SURPRISE
WAS AN ARMY OF BIKINI WAXERS.
I WAS SENT HERE
BY TYRA BANKS,
TO HAVE ALL THE GIRLS
WITH A BRAZILIAN BIKINI WAX.
WAIT, EXCUSE ME, YOU'RE GOING
TO GIVE US A BIKINI WAX?
- YES.
- DO WE HAVE TO?
YES.
♪♪
(laughing)
I'M DOING THIS, I CAN'T BELIEVE
I'M DOING THIS.
(tearing sound)
OH, MAN!
THAT WASN'T
THAT BAD, RIGHT?
OOH!
(chuckling)
Robin:
I FELT EXTREMELY UNCOMFORTABLE
WITH THE BIKINI WAX.
THERE'S ONLY TWO PEOPLE
THAT'S BEEN DOWN THERE:
MYSELF AND MY GYNECOLOGIST,
AND I GIVE HIM CRAP.
I AM REALLY SCARED.
I TOLD EVERYBODY IN MY WHOLE
LIFE, I SAID
"I WILL NEVER GET A BIKINI WAX."
OH! OH!
(whimpering)
(screaming)
Tessa: THERE WAS A FEW GIRLS,
THAT I THINK
WERE EXAGGERATING
A BIT TOO MUCH.
- (screaming)
- (tearing sound)
I BETTER BE
A DAMN SUPERMODEL AFTER THIS,
THAT'S ALL I HAVE TO SAY.
(sighing)
♪♪
IT WAS IMPORTANT FOR ME
TO SHOW THESE GIRLS
WHAT MODELING IS ALL ABOUT.
IT'S NOT ABOUT THE GLITZ
AND THE GLAMOUR.
IT'S ABOUT THE REAL.
SO I DECIDED
TO PUT THEM IN SWIMSUITS
ON A ROOFTOP
IN THE DEAD OF WINTER.
WAIT A MINUTE, I SAY IT'S ABOUT
20 DEGREES.
♪♪ WITHOUT A DOUBT NO DOUBT ♪
♪ WHAT IT IS WHERE IT'S AT
WHAT IT'S ABOUT ♪
♪ TRUDGING THROUGH THE
UNDERGROUND NUMBS ♪
♪ HERE TO MAP IT ALL OUT
BEFORE YOU BLACKOUT ♪
♪ PULLING YOU UP
OUT OF THE MIST ♪
♪ BRINGING YOU BACK TO THE
TRUENESS ♪
♪ WITHOUT A DOUBT NO DOUBT ♪
♪ WHAT IT IS WHERE IT'S AT
WHAT IT'S ABOUT ♪
♪ TRUDGING THROUGH
THE UNDERGROUND NUMBS ♪
♪ HERE TO MAP IT ALL OUT
BEFORE YOU BLACKOUT ♪
♪ PULLING YOU UP
OUT OF THE MIST ♪
♪ BRINGING YOU BACK
TO THE TRUENESS ♪♪
YOU KNOW WHAT,
CAN YOU BACK UP A LITTLE BIT?
HEAD DOWN,
LET YOUR HAND FLOP DOWN.
ONCE I GET YOU TO DO
STUFF THAT WE LIKE,
DON'T MOVE IT AROUND SO MUCH,
BECAUSE I'VE GOT YOU OVER HERE
AND THEN YOU'RE,
LIKE, OVER HERE.
- OKAY.
- YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN?
THERE YOU GO, THAT'S IT,
TOTALLY, THERE YOU GO.
PERFECT.
SHE PROBABLY HAD PEOPLE TEACH
HER HOW TO MODEL THE WRONG WAY.
THAT WAS HER PROBLEM.
Tyra:
THEN IT WAS TIME
FOR OUR FIRST ELIMINATION.
ALL RIGHT, LADIES.
THE TIME HAS ARRIVED
TO MAKE OUR FIRST CUT,
AND TO REMIND YOU, THE WINNER
WILL RECEIVE A CONTRACT
WITH REVLON COSMETICS,
A FASHION SPREAD
WITH MARIE CLAIRE MAGAZINE,
AND A MODELING CONTRACT
WITH ONE OF THE TOP AGENCIES
OF THE WORLD, WILHELMINA.
YOU'RE GOING TO BE JUDGED
ON YOUR NATURAL TALENT,
YOUR POTENTIAL
AND YOUR PERSONALITY
AS WELL AS YOUR PERFORMANCE
ON YOUR PHOTO SHOOT
THAT YOU TOOK YESTERDAY.
I THINK YOU NEED
TO LIVE A LITTLE BIT MORE.
YOU NEED TO EXPERIENCE
A LITTLE BIT MORE,
JUST GET MORE
ENGAGED IN YOUR FACE.
I DON'T NECESSARILY THINK
THAT THAT BATHING SUIT,
WHEN SHE CAME OUT,
WAS THE MOST FLATTERING ON HER.
I AM ALWAYS THE ONE THAT STEERS
AWAY FROM ANYTHING
THAT HAS TO DO
WITH LITTLE CLOTHES LIKE THAT.
I THINK YOU'RE CHOOSING
THE WRONG PROFESSION
IF YOU DON'T WANT TO BE
IN LITTLE THINGS
OR YOU TRY TO COVER UP.
Tyra:
IN THE END, IT WAS TESSA
WHO WAS ASKED TO PACK HER BAGS.
TESSA'S LOOK IS SO STRONG.
SHE COULD BE IN MAJOR MAGAZINES
AND SHE CAN BE IN COSMETIC ADS,
BUT WHEN IT COMES TO HER
PERSONALITY,
IT DIDN'T REALLY SHINE THROUGH.
IT DIDN'T JUMP AT THE JUDGES
LIKE "I'M A STAR."
Tessa:
THIS WAS A GREAT OPPORTUNITY
TO COME HERE, YOU KNOW?
I KEEP ON TELLING MYSELF,
LIKE, THAT'S AN ACCOMPLISHMENT
RIGHT THERE.
♪♪
Tyra:
ROBIN HAD TROUBLE
ACCEPTING ELYSE'S ATHEISM.
THERE HAVE BEEN SOME
UNCOMFORTABLE MOMENTS.
UM, ROBIN ACTUALLY SHOWED ME
THIS BIBLE VERSE.
IT WAS PSALM 14
AND IT STARTED OUT,
"FOOLISH IS THE MAN,
WHO SAYS THERE IS NO GOD."
I DON'T BELIEVE IN GOD,
AND IT WAS OFFENSIVE.
I DON'T KNOW
WHAT I'M SUPPOSED TO THINK.
WHEN I READ THAT,
THAT MADE ME THINK OF YOU.
♪♪
Tyra:
RUNWAY DIVA, J. ALEXANDER
PUT THE GIRLS THROUGH
THEIR PACES, LITERALLY.
WHAT YOU HOLDING
UP HERE, BABY?
MY BOOBIES.
OH, YOU ARE DOING
THE ONE-TIT WONDER.
YOU'RE ABOUT
TO DO LIKE THIS.
HE'S VERY DIRECT
WITH SOME OF THE GIRLS.
MARRY RICH
AND HAVE BABIES.
Tyra:
OF ALL THE GIRLS,
ELYSE FELT MOST OUT OF PLACE.
AND, UM, WHAT DO YOU WANT
TO DO AFTER THIS?
IF I DON'T WIN THIS CONTEST
START MEDICAL SCHOOL IN AUGUST.
- THAT'S A LOT OF WORK.
- OH, I KNOW.
Tyra:
BACK AT THE PENTHOUSE,
EVERYONE SEEMED
TO BE GETTING ALONG.
FIGHT, FIGHT?
WE BLACK, WE WOMEN.
I'M A LESBIAN,
SHE'S VOLUPTUOUS.
WE'RE DIFFERENT, WE'RE PEOPLE,
OKAY, TIME TO GO.
(laughing)
FOR WHAT?
LOOK AT HIS PENIS!
WHAT? EW!
DON'T LOOK AT NICOLE'S
BOYFRIEND'S PENIS.
DUDE, SHE WAS THE ONE
WHO SHOWED IT TO ME HERE.
Tyra:
ELYSE, HOWEVER,
WAS REACHING HER BREAKING POINT.
ROBIN, HOW (BLEEP) DARE YOU
SHOW ME THAT, "FOOLISH IS THEE"
ATHEIST BIBLE VERSE
THIS MORNING,
AND ASK ME
WHAT DO I THINK OF IT?
WHAT THE (BLEEP)
AM I SUPPOSED TO THINK OF IT?
YOU KNOW WHAT I THINK OF YOU?
FOOLISH IS A WOMAN WHO BELIEVES
THAT (BLEEP) DAMN TRIPE.
GISELLE, YOU (BLEEP)
WORTHLESS (BLEEP).
YOU ARE SO WASTEFUL,
BITCHY, STUPID.
YOU'RE WORTHLESS.
YOUR PARENTS MUST
BE ASHAMED OF YOU.
ADRIANNE, STOP INTERRUPTING ME.
STOP QUOTING JAY AND SILENT BOB
RIGHT NEXT TO MY EAR.
I'VE HAD ENOUGH OF YOU.
I DON'T WANT TO HEAR THE SAME
STORIES OVER AND OVER.
J., YOU OFFENDED ME TODAY.
I KNOW THAT MEDICAL SCHOOL
IS HARD WORK.
HOW CAN I POSSIBLY
NOT BE AWARE OF THAT?
AND SECONDLY, HOW DARE YOU IMPLY
THAT I'M UPPITY
BECAUSE I WANT TO BE
A LIFESAVER AND YOU DON'T?
IT TAKES A (BLEEP) ASS TO COVER
EVERY SEAT, YOU (BLEEP).
WHAT ELSE?
KATIE, I DON'T BELIEVE A WORD
THAT COMES OUT OF YOUR MOUTH.
YOU'RE THE MOST INSINCERE PERSON
I'VE EVER MET.
(BLEEP) DAMN IT,
LET ME (BLEEP) DIE.
YOU ARE...
YOU BITCHES.
♪♪
Tyra:
AS THE GIRLS BEGAN THEIR
SECOND WEEK IN THE PENTHOUSE,
THE COMPETITION
BEGAN TO HEAT UP.
Ebony:
GIRLS, EMERGENCY LETTER!
LET ME READ IT.
DO WE HAVE TO WAIT
FOR EVERYBODY?
NO, WE DON'T.
"YOU'LL BE UNDERTAKING
YOUR SECOND PHOTO SHOOT,
"WITH STUFF MAGAZINE
TOMORROW MORNING.
BE READY TO GO
IN THE APARTMENT AT 7:30."
Robin: WHEN WE GOT THE NOTE,
WE WERE LIKE,
"WELL, THE OTHER GIRLS
ARE ALREADY GONE,"
AND SO THEN WE SAID,
"WELL, OKAY,
WE'RE GOING
TO GO DOWN AND TELL THEM."
WELL, ROBIN, YOU KNOW, "HEY,
I'M GOING DOWN TO GET THEM."
YOU KNOW, GREAT, FABULOUS.
YOU BE THE ANGEL FOR TODAY.
I SAID, I WOULD NOT HAVE
WENT DOWNSTAIRS TO TELL THEM.
Tyra: THE NEXT DAY,
ALL HELL BROKE LOOSE.
THERE IS A DIFFERENCE
IN A GOOD COMPETITOR
AND A COMPETITOR
THAT HAS BAD VIBES.
AND ONE PERSON CAN GIVE, LIKE,
THE WHOLE HOUSE A BAD VIBE.
I WASN'T PURPOSELY
TRYING TO HOLD IT TO MYSELF.
AND I'M NOT GOING
TO EXPLAIN THAT AGAIN.
IF YOU WANT TO TAKE THAT ENERGY
AS THOUGH
I REALLY MEANT NOBODY
WAS GOING DOWNSTAIRS,
NO, YOU GUYS ARE NOT GOING
TO GO, THEN THAT'S FINE.
YOU KNOW WHAT?
THOSE DEMONS THAT YOU HAVE
WITHIN YOURSELF,
ARE GOING TO COME OUT,
AND YOU GOING TO WONDER WHY
NOBODY WANTS TO BE AROUND YOU.
I MADE IT CLEAR FROM THE GET-GO,
THIS IS A COMPETITION.
I FEEL AS THOUGH YOU GUYS
MIGHT EXPECT CERTAIN THINGS.
I DON'T FEEL AS THOUGH THIS IS
HIGH SCHOOL OR A GROUP SESSION.
EBONY WAS JUST OFF ON HER RANTS
THAT SHE GOES ON.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO AGREE WITH ME.
THAT'S THE THING
ABOUT A COMPETITION!
THAT'S RIGHT,
YOU'RE CUTTING YOU OFF.
THIS IS WHY I'M TALKING
ABOUT BEING A GROWN WOMAN.
YOU HAVE AN OPINION
YOU WANT TO SAY,
I DEFINITELY WANT TO HEAR IT,
BUT CUTTING ME OFF
IS NOT GOING TO WORK.
I DON'T UNDERSTAND HOW ANYBODY
CANNOT ANALYZE THAT
FROM GET ONE.
DID I MAKE THAT VERY CLEAR?
ROBIN STARTED SINGING.
I DIDN'T REALLY UNDERSTAND
WHAT WAS REALLY GOING ON
WITH THAT EITHER.
(singing)
I'M TALKING AND YOU'RE SINGING
IN THE MIDDLE
OF ME TALKING, ROBIN.
(singing)
♪ HOW EXCELLENT, EXCELLENT ♪
♪ IS THY NAME ♪
I'M SORRY, BUT THE BIBLE
SAYING IS NOT...
ROBIN SORT OF
CALMED EVERYONE DOWN
BY MAKING US ALL SAY A PRAYER.
EVERY HEAD BOWED
AND EVERY EYE CLOSED.
PEOPLE ARE TAKING THE WORD
COMPETITIVENESS
AND I TURN THIS
DEFINITION AROUND, LORD.
LORD, I ASK THAT YOU REMOVE
ANY NEGATIVE THING
AND DON'T LET US LOOK
TO BE VINDICTIVE
AND CATTY AND SELF-RIGHTEOUS
AND ALL OF THOSE OTHER THINGS
THAT ARE OF DEMONIC PRESENCE
AND BIND SATAN, JESUS.
I ASK YOU BIND HIM.
BIND HIM RIGHT NOW, LORD.
BIND HIM
RIGHT NOW, JESUS.
AMEN AND AMEN.
WHEN IT COMES TO PRAYER, I WILL
ALWAYS HOLD HANDS AND HOPE.
BUT ROBIN
THIS IS NOT A SORORITY.
Robin:
Y'ALL READY?
I'M SORRY THIS IS A MODEL
COMPETITION.
Tyra: A TOP MODEL HAS TO APPEAL
TO EVERYONE.
TO KIDS, TO WOMEN,
AND TO MEN.
SO I CHOSE STUFF MAGAZINE
AS AN OUTLET
TO SEE HOW THEY CAN CONNECT
TO A MALE AUDIENCE.
♪♪ WE WANT YOU
TO TAKE A GOOD LOOK ♪
♪ AT WHAT WE DO ♪
♪ YOU CAN SEE RIGHT THROUGH ♪
♪ BECAUSE YOU NEVER KNOW
WHAT WE MIGHT DO ♪
♪ UH-HUH, UH-HUH ♪
♪ LOOKING IN YOUR EYES ♪
♪ WE WANT YOU
TO TAKE A GOOD LOOK ♪♪
Katie:
WORDS CAN'T EVEN DESCRIBE,
THAT'S MY DREAM,
TO BE ON THE COVER
OF STUFF MAGAZINE.
THE SEX APPEAL AND STUFF,
THAT'S JUST ME, TOTALLY.
Tyra: FOR KATIE, IT WAS ALSO
THE END OF A DREAM,
WHEN THE JUDGES FELT SHE LACKED
THE VERSATILITY
TO GO FURTHER
IN THE COMPETITION.
I JUST FEEL LIKE SHE WOULD
MAKE A GREAT MODEL
FOR SWIMSUIT CALENDARS,
AND FOR LIKE CAR MAGAZINES
AND THAT TYPE OF STUFF,
BUT I DON'T SEE HER...
I CAN'T SEE HER WALKING DOWN
KARL LAGERFELD'S RUNWAY.
Quillian:
SHE'S NOT SPECIAL,
THE WAY THAT A MODEL
NEEDS TO BE.
Katie:
I KNOW THAT THEY'RE BRINGING UP
LIKE HOW MAYBE I WAS LIKE,
TOO SEXY.
I CAN'T HELP THAT SO IT'S JUST
HOW I AM NATURALLY.
I'M TOTALLY STILL
GOING TO GO FOR IT.
I'LL BE ON THE COVERS
OF MAGAZINES, YOU'LL SEE ME.
♪♪
Tyra:
NICOLE WAS FINDING IT HARD
BEING AWAY FROM HER BOYFRIEND.
BUT BEING A TOP MODEL
MEANS BEING AWAY
FROM LOVED ONES A LOT.
HEY, HONEY, IT'S ME.
HEY, BABY DOLL, IT'S ME.
HEY, IT'S ME.
Adrianne: NICOLE TOLD ME
THAT SHE WOULD GIVE UP
BEING A SUPERMODEL
IF SHE COULD NOT TALK
TO HER BOYFRIEND.
WHICH I WAS LIKE,
WHAT GUY IN THE WORLD
IS BETTER THAN BEING
A SUPERMODEL?
Tyra: AND WHEN IT CAME TIME
FOR MAKEOVERS,
NICOLE WANTED
TO HOLD ON TO HER WEAVE.
♪♪
YOU DO LOOK LIKE
A DIFFERENT PERSON.
GIRL, I KNOW.
Tyra:
A FEW GIRLS HAD TROUBLE
ADJUSTING TO THEIR NEW LOOKS.
- IT IS UNEVEN.
- YEAH.
WINDS UP SHAVING
HER HEAD THAT BAD?
IT'S VERY UPSETTING TO
AN AFRICAN AMERICAN WOMAN
TO GO INTO A SALON,
AND THE PERSON TO DO
HER HAIR INCORRECTLY.
IT IS VERY INAPPROPRIATE.
A PERSON COULD BE VIOLENT.
EBONY GETS GOING
AND CANNOT STOP
AND IT'S A LITTLE BIT WEIRD.
I COULD HAVE BEEN
CRAZY UP IN THERE.
BUT OF COURSE
THAT'S NOT MY PERSONALITY.
THE SALON WAS BEAUTIFUL,
THE MAKEUP WAS FABULOUS,
THE PEOPLE WERE GREAT,
BUT IT'S JUST VERY INTERESTING,
HOW YOU HAVE A SALON
THAT'S LIMITED.
YOU NEED TO LET THAT BE KNOWN.
MY SALON IS LIMITED.
WE REALLY DO NOT CUT
AFRICAN AMERICAN HAIR,
AND THAT'S THE PROCEDURE.
BUT WHEN YOU DON'T
LET THAT KNOWN
AND YOU PRETEND YOU CAN DO THAT
AND PLAY WITH SOMEBODY'S HAIR,
THAT COULD BE DANGEROUS.
- YEP.
- NO, NO, THAT'S MESSED UP.
IT'S MESSED UP,
I DON'T UNDERSTAND.
TYRA WOULD NOT HAVE THIS.
WAIT, GIRL, DO IT
ONE MORE TIME.
GIRL, IT'S HOPELESS.
THIS IS NOT A STYLE,
IT'S HORRIBLE.
OH, MY GOD,
IT'S RIDICULOUS.
Tyra:
THE NEXT DAY,
NICOLE HAD THE CHANCE
TO ATTEND A MAJOR FASHION EVENT
AND TURNED IT DOWN.
- WHY DON'T YOU WANT TO GO?
- I AM NOT FEELING VERY GOOD,
I HAVE A LITTLE STOMACHACHE--
YOU REALIZE YOU COULD BE PUTTING
SOMEONE ELSE AHEAD OF YOU?
YOU COULD JUST BE
CUT THIS WEEK.
WELL, IF I'M CUT THIS WEEK
BECAUSE OF THIS,
THEN THAT'S JUST SILLY.
SO THEN IT'S SILLY AND YOU GO
BACK HOME AND YOU DO WHAT?
WORK AT BURGER KING?
YOU KNOW WHAT?
OKAY, NO, I'M NOT GOING.
YOU DON'T THINK I HAVE
FAKE EYELASHES ON, RIGHT?
CAN YOU NOT TALK TO ME
ABOUT YOUR EYELASHES?
- I REALLY DON'T CARE.
- WHOA, DUDE, I'M SORRY.
Adrianne:
NICOLE NOT WANTING TO GO,
I THINK THAT WAS KIND OF DUMB.
IN A WAY, I THINK SHE KIND
OF WANTED TO GO HOME
AND JUST CALL HER BOYFRIEND.
Tyra:
SO WHILE SOME OF THE GIRLS
GOT TO STRUT
THEIR STUFF FOR VIPS,
NICOLE PHONED HOME.
I HAVE CALLED YOU EVERY SINGLE
DAY, FOUR TIMES A DAY,
FOR THE LAST SIX DAYS.
DID YOU TRY TO CALL
ME YESTERDAY?
- NO.
- DAY BEFORE?
NO.
DAY BEFORE?
NO, I HAVEN'T TRIED
TO CALL YOU AT ALL.
♪♪
Tyra:
WITH THEIR FIERCE NEW LOOKS,
THE GIRLS WERE READY
FOR AN EXTREME BEAUTY SHOOT.
WE HAVE ANOTHER MODEL THAT
YOU'RE GOING TO WORK WITH
THAT YOU DON'T KNOW ABOUT.
WE'VE BROUGHT MODELS IN
FROM ALL OVER THE WORLD
TO BE WITH US HERE.
♪♪
Robin: I'VE NEVER TOUCHED
A SNAKE BEFORE.
I DON'T PLAY WITH
REPTILES AND YOU KNOW,
AMPHIBIANS AND ALL THAT STUFF.
- YOU FEEL GORGEOUS?
- YES.
YOU HAVE TO BELIEVE IT.
BECAUSE IF YOU DON'T BELIEVE IT,
I DON'T BELIEVE IT.
I THOUGHT THAT
WAS THE SNAKE.
THERE'S A LOT OF EMOTION
IN YOUR EYES NOW.
THAT'S GOOD, BABY,
I BELIEVE IT.
EW, GET HIM, GET HIM, GET HIM.
I HAD TO CALL ON JESUS.
I DON'T KNOW HOW MANY TIMES.
OH, JESUS,
JESUS, JESUS.
TAKE A BREATH,
TAKE A BREATH.
JESUS.
THE END PRODUCT IS GLAMOROUS,
BUT WHAT IT TAKES TO GET
TO THAT IS NOT SO GLAMOROUS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
Tyra: THAT NIGHT,
THE GIRLS RECEIVED A TYRA MAIL.
"TOMORROW SEVEN OF YOU
WILL CONTINUE ON
"TO BECOME
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
ONE OF YOU WILL BE ELIMINATED."
- WE HAVE OUR HYPOTHESIS.
- RIGHT.
UM, AND WE THINK THE NEXT
GIRL TO BE CUT WILL BE...
- GIS...
- SELLE.
THEY WERE STARING AT YOUR
PICTURES FOREVER, NICOLE.
- WHAT DOES THAT MEAN?
- I DON'T KNOW.
YOU'RE BEING ELIMINATED, NICOLE,
THAT'S WHAT IT MEANS.
YEAH, RIGHT,
I'M NOT GOING NOWHERE.
I STILL HAVE TWO MORE WEEKS
WORTH OF CLOTHES, BABY.
YOU BETTER
WORK IT OUT.
Tyra: THE NEXT MORNING,
ADRIANNE WAS NOT HERSELF.
ADRIANNE IS SICK, GUYS.
I GO OVER AND CHECK ON HER,
AND SHE'S IN THE BATHROOM,
SHIVERING AND CRYING.
OKAY, HERE WE GOT YOU.
I DON'T WANT TO STAND UP
STRAIGHT PLEASE.
PUT THE BLANKET ON HER.
SHE'S BEING SHIPPED OFF
TO THE HOSPITAL RIGHT NOW,
AND IT'S REALLY SAD.
Tyra: AS THE MINUTES WOUND DOWN,
NO ONE KNEW WHETHER ADRIANNE
WOULD MAKE IT BACK
FOR THE JUDGING.
THE DOCTOR TOLD ME IT WAS
A SEVERE CASE OF FOOD POISONING.
I FAKED BEING BETTER
TO GET OUT OF THE HOSPITAL.
Tyra: ADRIANNE MADE IT BACK
IN TIME FOR THE JUDGING,
ACED THE EXTREME MAKEUP TEST,
AND ESCAPED ELIMINATION.
IN THE END, IT WAS
BETWEEN EBONY AND NICOLE.
NICOLE, YOUR PHOTO SHOOTS,
I FEEL LIKE YOU REALLY
NEED TO WORK ON
YOUR FACIAL EXPRESSIONS,
ESPECIALLY YOUR EYES.
I FEEL LIKE WHATEVER
WORRY THAT YOU HAVE
COMES THROUGH
IN YOUR PICTURES.
EBONY, THE COLOR OF YOUR SKIN
IS SO BEAUTIFUL,
BUT THE TEXTURE OF
YOUR SKIN NEEDS A LOT OF WORK.
EBONY, CONGRATULATIONS.
♪♪
Nicole:
I REALLY DON'T HAVE
ANY REGRETS
SINCE I'VE BEEN HERE.
THERE'S DEFINITELY A RELIEF
THAT I'M GOING HOME,
AND IT'S A SMALL ONE,
AND THAT WOULD PROBABLY BE
JUST TO BE WITH MY BOYFRIEND.
Tyra: AFTER HER CLOSE CALL
IN THE JUDGING,
EBONY'S SKIN REGIMEN
BECAME A LITTLE EXCESSIVE.
IT'S SUPPOSED TO MAKE
MY SKIN FABULOUS.
Elyse:
THERE WAS GREASE ALL OVER,
BECAUSE OF HER
NEW MOISTURIZING REGIME.
GREASE ALL OVER THE DOORKNOB,
GREASE ON THE PHONE,
GREASE ALL OVER TOKYO.
Tyra: MEANWHILE, EBONY
WAS HAVING HER OWN PROBLEMS
WITH GISELLE OVER HOUSE CHORES.
Ebony:
GISELLE DID NOT CLEAN THE TUB,
DID NOT TOUCH THE WINDOWS,
DID NOT MOP THE FLOOR,
DID NOT REMOVE TOWELS.
SO I JUST HAD TO GIVE IT TO HER
FOR TWO MINUTES,
BECAUSE SHE NEEDED IT.
NOBODY'S GOING TO LIKE YOU!
NO, SERIOUSLY, YOU'RE DOING
THAT STUPID AGE THING AGAIN.
- WHAT STUPID AGE THING?
- BRING UP THE AGE.
SWEETIE, I'M NOT GOING THROUGH
IT WITH YOU.
- I JUST DON'T UNDERSTAND.
- I'M NOT GOING
THROUGH WITH YOU.
I DON'T UNDERSTAND!
I NEED TO ASK YOU A QUESTION.
SWEETIE, CAN YOU
UNDERSTAND WHAT I'M SAYING?
IT'S BABBLING TALKING TO YOU.
YOU'RE MY ROOMMATE
AND I NEED TO GET
ALONG WITH MY ROOMMATES
AND I DON'T UNDERSTAND WHY
YOU HAVE TO ACT LIKE THAT.
YOU KNOW WHAT, SWEETIE?
GO AND TALK TO SOMEBODY ELSE
ABOUT IT.
DON'T DO IT WITH ME,
BECAUSE I AM VERY INTELLIGENT,
AND I'M NOT GOING TO PLAY
THIS LITTLE SLOW GAME WITH YOU.
THAT 18-YEAR-OLD,
AND ME, YOU KNOW, TRYING TO BE
A GREAT ROLE MODEL AND ALL THAT,
THAT NEEDS A CUT AT ONE POINT.
THIS IS A COMPETITION.
Tyra:
THE DRAMA HEATED UP EVEN FURTHER
WHEN EBONY GOT A VISIT
FROM HER GIRLFRIEND KA.
YOU SO CRAZY.
Robin: EBONY IS A LESBIAN,
AND I FIND THIS OFFENSIVE.
BUT I CAN'T STOP HER,
YOU KNOW,
FROM HAVING SOMEONE OVER,
SO EVERYBODY HAS TO DEAL
WITH THEIR OWN SIN.
I DON'T PERSONALLY, LIKE,
AGREE WITH IT.
CAN YOU TELL ME WHY
YOU DON'T AGREE WITH IT?
I MEAN, JUST BECAUSE,
YOU KNOW, I DON'T AGREE WITH,
YOU KNOW...
YOU KNOW, LIKE, LESBIAN
AND GAY RELATIONSHIPS.
♪♪
Tyra:
MODELS ARE OFTEN CALLED UPON
TO JUST SHUT UP AND LOOK PRETTY.
CONTRARY TO POPULAR BELIEF,
TOP MODELS NEED TO KNOW
HOW TO SPEAK, TOO.
SO AS PART OF THE COMPETITION,
I HAD THEM SHOOT A COMMERCIAL
FOR CONTACT LENSES,
IN WHICH THE GIRLS
NEEDED TO WALK,
TALK, DANCE, AND LOOK GORGEOUS
ALL AT THE SAME TIME.
ACTION.
COLOR'S INTRIGUE.
COLOR IS POWER.
PASSION.
"PAAASSION" OR PASSION?
AM I SAYING
IT RIGHT AT ALL?
YO, YOU'VE GOT TO HELP ME OUT.
YOU'RE NOT EVEN CLOSE.
(BLEEP).
ONE MORE SHOT,
YOU GOT ONE MORE CHANCE AT IT.
PASSION.
OKAY, YOU'RE CONSISTENT.
AND FRESH LOOK
IS COLOR FOR YOUR EYES.
DO US A FAVOR, WHEN YOU WALK OUT
AND DO THAT SCENE,
TRY NOT TO DO THE
HOP WITH YOUR SHOES.
GOT IT.
YOU CAN HEAR THAT CLICK, CLICK,
CLICK, CLATTER, OKAY?
THREE, TWO, ACTION.
AND FRESH LOOK
IS COLOR FOR YOUR EYES.
SHE FORGOT ALL THE STEPS
THAT SHE LEARNED
FROM THE CHOREOGRAPHER
AND COULDN'T QUITE, YOU KNOW,
GET IT IN THERE.
- THANK YOU, EBONY.
Tyra:
IN THE END, EBONY'S AWKWARDNESS
LED TO HER DISMISSAL.
GISELLE, CONGRATULATIONS.
THANK YOU, EBONY.
WHOA, SHE JUST WALKED OUT
WITHOUT EVEN SAYING ANYTHING.
EBONY WANTED THIS SO BAD.
SHE LIVED IT,
SHE BREATHED IT, SHE ATE IT.
SOMETIMES WANTING IT
IS NOT ENOUGH.
Ebony:
I'M HURT, BUT...
IT'S ALMOST, AS FAST AS YOU
CAN THINK ABOUT THE DREAM,
HOW FAST CAN YOU
THINK ABOUT
THAT NEXT DREAM
OR THE NEXT STEP?
I'M STILL PROUD OF MYSELF
THAT I'M ABLE
TO HOLD MYSELF UP.
AND TYRA, SHE COULDN'T SEE HOW
HAPPY I WAS TO BE THERE.
- AW!
- I WANT TO READ THIS.
"TO AMERICA'S NEXT
TOP MODEL, FROM EBONY."
- IT'S GOING TO MAKE YOU CRY.
- AW.
"DEAR LADIES, ADRIANNE, ROBIN,
GISELLE, ELYSE, KESSE..."
OH, WHERE'S MY NAME AT?
(chuckling)
- OKAY, GO ON.
- OH, COME ON.
"I AM SORRY I DIDN'T
SAY GOOD-BYE.
"THANK YOU FOR BEING IN MY LIFE.
LADIES, YOU BETTER WORK IT."
"GISELLE, LIKE YOURSELF SO MUCH
"THAT ALL YOU CAN DO
IS LOVE YOURSELF.
NEXT TIME, GET YOUR OWN OIL.
THE NEXT TIME, PRETTY GIRL."
AW.
"EBONY."
Tyra:
BUT THE HOUSE SOON DIVIDED
OVER ANOTHER ISSUE--
ELYSE'S DIET.
THIS IS YOURS.
(chatter)
YOU KNOW, THOUGH I FELT SORRY
FOR HER LAST NIGHT
WHEN SHE WAS EATING
ALL THAT FOOD
'CAUSE, POOR CHILD,
I WAS, LIKE, "LORD, I HOPE
SHE DOESN'T THROW UP."
OH, MY GOD, SHE WAS...
AS SOON AS WE GOT HERE,
"GUYS, YOU NEED
TO HURRY UP IN THAT BATHROOM."
IT DOESN'T SEEM LIKE
YOU'RE EVER HUNGRY.
I GUESS IT'S, LIKE,
IT'S GOOD,
'CAUSE YOU'RE HAPPY
WITH YOURSELF.
I'M SKINNY,
BUT I LIKE IT.
I'M SO DEFENSIVE,
BECAUSE I NEVER GET A CHANCE
TO EXPLAIN MYSELF, EVER.
WE BOTH SWEAR THAT WE HEARD...
(feigns gagging)
AND THEN, LIKE,
WITH THE WATER, AND THEN
WE HEARD THE TOILET FLUSH.
I DON'T KNOW,
HER TEETH ARE NOT AS SHINY.
THEY'RE YELLOW.
Elyse: I AM APPLYING
TO MEDICAL SCHOOL AND, UM,
I CAN CONFIDENTLY SAY
THAT I KNOW MORE
ABOUT EATING DISORDERS
THAN ALL OF THE REST
OF THE GIRLS COMBINED.
I DON'T QUIT ANYTHING.
SO, NO WAY, YOU'D EVER...
NO, BUT I'M SURE
I'LL GET ELIMINATED.
BUT YOU'RE NOT GOING TO GET
ELIMINATED BEFORE ME.
Tyra:
THE NEXT DAY, THE GIRLS HAD
A SHOOT FEATURING MOVEMENT.
IT IS SO IMPORTANT
FOR A TOP MODEL
TO KNOW HOW
TO MOVE HER BODY WELL.
♪♪ TO MY WARRIOR'S GONE
STOKELY, GEORGE JACKSON, HUEY ♪
♪ IF YOU FEELIN' ME WE SHOULD BE
FAMILY VANITY ♪
♪ HOLD US BACK MENTALLY
MY BROTHER BE STRONG ♪
♪ 'TIL THE TIME COME
WISDOM UPON THE DRUM ♪
♪ WHERE WE COME FROM GUNS
CLAP THE SUN ♪
♪ RETURN OF
THE BLACK WILLIAM WALLACE ♪
♪ 2002 SHAKA ZULU WITH TWO BLACK
STEEL REVOLVERS ♪
♪ IN THE COMMUNITY ALL OF US
GOT TO GET INVOLVED... ♪
Tyra: HAVING WON AWARDS
AT AN EARLIER COMPETITION,
ELYSE AND ADRIANNE
RECEIVED VISITORS.
CHEWBACCA!
MAMA!
HEY, WHEN YOU'RE DONE
GETTING THAT, UH, THE PASTA,
PASS IT DOWN HERE.
YOU WANT SOME FISH, GIRL?
I DON'T KNOW WHAT'S GOING ON
WITH ELYSE WITH HER EATING.
Elyse's boyfriend:
THIS EATING DISORDER
NONSENSE IS RIDICULOUS.
BINGE, PURGE.
ELYSE IS THE PERSON
THAT RIGHT AFTER WE'VE
FINISHED EATING,
ALREADY WANTS TO GO
GET AN ICE-CREAM CONE
AND A KIT KAT.
Adrianne:
ELYSE AND HER BOYFRIEND
JUST MADE OUT, LIKE,
ALL NIGHT
AND IT WAS REALLY DISGUSTING
AND I JUST KIND OF
HELD ON TO MY MA.
I LOVE YOU,
I'M GOING TO WIN.
- GOOD, GOOD LUCK.
- I LOVE YOU, MAMA.
I LOVE YOU, TOO.
Tyra:
FOR GISELLE,
SELF-ESTEEM WAS BECOMING
A MAJOR ISSUE.
I NEED TO BUILD SOME
FRICKING CONFIDENCE.
HOW DO I DO THAT?
YOU GET OUT OF PUBERTY.
Adrianne: GISELLE FOUND OUT
THAT PRETENDING TO BE
SO NEGATIVE ABOUT YOURSELF
AND SO INSECURE
IS A GREAT WAY
TO FISH FOR COMPLIMENTS.
MY PICTURES CAME OUT
THE WORST OUT OF EVERYBODY.
NO, THEY DIDN'T,
YOU'RE TRIPPING.
AM I NOT GOING TO EVER
BE ABLE TO DO A COMMERCIAL?
I HAVE A THIRD EYEBALL
ON MY FACE.
LIKE WHAT THE HELL
AM I DOING HERE?
I AM GOING TO BED.
COME OVER HERE,
LET'S DO A SLIP AND SLIDE.
EW.
I'LL SLIDE, YOU SLIP.
DO YOU ACTUALLY THINK,
EVEN IF I WAS A LESBIAN,
THAT I'D BE REMOTELY
ATTRACTED TO YOU?
YOU'RE NOT MY TYPE.
IF I WAS A LESBIAN,
YOU WOULD HAVE TO LOOK LIKE
A STRAIGHT-UP DUDE
AND I'M SORRY,
THAT JUST SHOWS
HOW NOT GAY I AM.
Tyra: THE NEXT NIGHT
WAS THE FIFTH ELIMINATION.
I LIKE HOW YOU LOOK YOUNG
BUT SEXY AT THE SAME TIME.
THIS LOOKS LIKE SHE ESCAPED
FROM A MENTAL INSTITUTION.
THIS IS THE WORST PHOTOGRAPH
I'VE EVER SEEN.
YOU LOOK DERANGED,
YOUR ARMS LOOK AMPUTEED,
YOUR LEGS LOOK AMPUTEED
AND IT LOOKS LIKE YOU
HAVE A PENIS, I'M SORRY.
THIS, TO ME, DOES NOT
REPRESENT MOVEMENT AT ALL.
YOU LOOK INSANE.
Tyra: BUT IN THE END,
IT WAS GISELLE'S
INSECURITY ISSUES
THAT STOOD OUT MOST.
GISELLE, DURING THE PHOTO SHOOT,
I THOUGHT YOU
WERE THE BEST.
BUT YOU WALKED OFF
THE STAGE AND YOU SAID,
"I THINK I MESSED UP,"
AND YOU MADE
MY MIND CHANGE.
CONGRATULATIONS, ELYSE.
GISELLE IS SO INSECURE,
AND IT'S SO SAD,
'CAUSE THAT IS A BEAUTIFUL GIRL.
BUT SHE HAS NO CONFIDENCE,
AND TO BE A TOP MODEL,
YOU HAVE TO HAVE CONFIDENCE.
Giselle: I JUST KNEW THAT
IT WAS MY TIME TO GO.
MY MOM, I KNOW SHE'S
GOING TO RUB IT IN MY FACE,
SO THAT'LL PROBABLY
BE THE ONLY THING.
I'M GOING TO FEEL CRAPPY.
IF I'M COMING HOME,
IT'S BECAUSE
OBVIOUSLY I DIDN'T
DO SO WELL HERE.
♪♪
Tyra: AFTER GISELLE LEFT,
THE GIRLS WERE FLOWN TO PARIS,
THE FASHION CAPITAL
OF THE WORLD,
WHERE THEY CHECKED
INTO THEIR HOTEL.
YOU GUYS OKAY DOWN THERE?
Tyra:
THERE WEREN'T ENOUGH BEDS,
SO THE GIRLS DREW NAMES
FOR THE AIR MATTRESS.
THREE BEDS AND THEN THE AIR BED.
Tyra:
ROBIN LOST.
Robin: MY NAME WAS LAST,
SO I GOT THE AIR MATTRESS.
ROBIN SLEEPS ON THE FLOOR.
I MEAN, I'M NOT, YOU KNOW,
SO SPECIAL WHERE I CAN'T SLEEP
ON THE AIR MATTRESS.
ROBIN'S GOT TO SLEEP
ON THE FLOOR.
I'VE SLEPT ON ONE BEFORE,
AND IT WASN'T EVEN INFLATED.
ROBIN HAS TO SLEEP ON THE FLOOR,
MISS PAGEANTRY.
Tyra: ADRIANNE AND ROBIN HAD
DISAGREEMENTS OVER VOCABULARY.
Adrianne:
HOW DO YOU SAY,
"ADRIANNE HAS
ENORMOUS CHA-CHAS?"
(Elyse speaking French)
ELYSE, HOW BAD DOES
YOUR COOCH SMELL?
HOW DO YOU SAY THAT?
(speaking French)
ADRIANNE, WHEN SHE SAYS THINGS
THAT ARE INAPPROPRIATE,
I MIGHT LOOK AT HER
IN A WAY THAT THE TEACHER
WOULD LOOK AT YOU
IF YOU DID SOMETHING
INAPPROPRIATE IN CLASS.
I DON'T SPEAK LIKE THAT.
I DON'T ACT LIKE THAT.
I DON'T WANT TO HEAR THAT.
♪♪
Tyra: THE NEXT MORNING
THERE WAS A FASHION SHOOT
FEATURING LINGERIE,
WHICH LED TO SOME
INTIMATE CONVERSATION.
DO YOU THINK IT'S OKAY
TO MASTURBATE?
WE ALREADY HAD
THIS CONVERSATION,
BUT I WANT TO SEE WHAT
YOUR OPINION IS.
I'VE NEVER DONE IT BEFORE,
BUT I DON'T KNOW.
I KNEW A GUY,
WHAT HE DID, BUT...
YEAH, BUT WE'RE NOT TALKING
ABOUT MEN RIGHT NOW.
I DIDN'T KNOW WE COULD DO IT,
LIKE, TO OURSELVES.
Robin:
MISS SHANNON'S 18 YEARS OLD.
SHE'S STILL A VIRGIN,
BELIEVES IN THE LORD.
Shannon: AND I'VE NEVER HAD
A SERIOUS BOYFRIEND,
NEVER REALLY HAD A BOYFRIEND,
SO I'M JUST LIKE, UH!
PLEASE, LORD,
SEND ME SOMEBODY SOMETIME.
I GOT TO MEET BRAD.
I HUNG UP THIS
GUY NAMED BRAD PINKERT.
I SAW HIM IN LIKE THIS MAGAZINE
AND WHAT CAUGHT MY EYE
WAS THAT HIS FAVORITE BOOK
WAS THE BIBLE.
HE LOOKS MIGHTY FINE TO ME.
WHEREVER YOU ARE, BOY,
I'M GOING TO COME FIND YOU.
Tyra: LITTLE DID SHANNON KNOW
THAT HER DREAM
WAS ABOUT TO BECOME REALITY.
OH, MY WORD!
- HOW YOU DOING?
- GOOD.
- I'M BRAD.
- SHANNON.
NICE TO MEET YOU.
OH, MY WORD! YOU GUYS, NO!
IT WAS BRAD PINKERT--
THE GUY I'VE BEEN
TALKING ABOUT THIS WHOLE TRIP.
I WAS GRABBING HIM
AND I WAS LIKE,
I'VE NEVER
BEEN IN THIS POSITION BEFORE.
AND HE'S GOT SOME MUSCLES, MAN,
HE'S GOT SOME MUSCLES.
♪♪
Tyra: THAT NIGHT SHANNON GOT
TO KNOW BRAD EVEN BETTER.
(woman singing in French)
Shannon:
AT TIMES, I ENJOY BEING SINGLE,
BECAUSE I'VE BEEN SINGLE
FOR I DON'T KNOW HOW LONG,
BUT DEEP DOWN I THINK
I'D ENJOY HAVING A BOYFRIEND,
JUST BECAUSE I'M A ROMANTIC.
♪♪ POUR LES AMOUREUX ♪
♪ MON COEUR... ♪♪
Robin: TODAY WE'RE GOING
TO GO DO GO SEES.
YOU GO SEE A CLIENT.
THEY GIVE YOU FEEDBACK
ON WHETHER OR NOT THEY LIKE YOU.
♪♪
Tyra:
THE LAST STOP FOR ALL THE GIRLS
WAS A MEETING WITH THE JUDGES.
EARLIER TODAY YOU COMPLETED
YOUR TESTS WHEN MARILYN SENT YOU
ALL AROUND PARIS ON GO SEES.
HOW MANY OF THE GO SEES
DID YOU MANAGE TO DO TODAY?
I DID ALL OF THEM.
I MADE ALL FOUR.
- I MADE ALL OF THEM.
- I WENT TO THREE.
YOU ONLY WENT TO THREE?
- YES.
- WHAT HAPPENED?
I LOST TRACK OF TIME,
IT WAS MY OWN FAULT.
I SHOULD HAVE BEEN
CHECKING ON TIME, SO...
FOR A GIRL TO JUST NOT SHOW UP
FOR SOME AIMLESS REASON,
IT'S POINTS OFF FOR ME.
BEING A TOP MODEL IS ALSO ABOUT
DOING A PERSONAL APPEARANCE,
AND KNOCKING EVERYBODY DEAD.
I'M NOT SURE SHE CAN DO THAT.
IN THE END, IT WAS KESSE
WHO HAD TO GO HOME.
WHEN KESSE WAS ELIMINATED,
ALL THE JUDGES WERE CRYING
THAT NIGHT, ACTUALLY.
FOR SOME REASON THAT ONE
WAS A REALLY HARD ONE
FOR US TO LET GO.
Kesse: IT REALLY HASN'T
FELT LIKE A COMPETITION,
BECAUSE WE'VE JUST BEEN HAVING
SO MUCH FUN HANGING OUT
AND REALLY GETTING
TO KNOW EACH OTHER.
OUT OF THOUSANDS OF GIRLS,
I'VE LASTED TO THE TOP FIVE,
AND THERE ARE NOT MANY GIRLS
THAT CAN SAY
THEY'VE DONE THAT, YOU KNOW?
'CAUSE I WAS REALLY
GETTING EMOTIONAL
JUST THINKING ABOUT LEAVING
THEM, NOT REALLY ABOUT...
(sighing)
Adrianne: I'M RELIEVED,
BUT THEN I FEEL BAD,
'CAUSE I LOVE KESSE,
YOU KNOW?
HOW BAD IS MY MAKEUP?
HORRIBLE.
♪♪
Tyra:
CONFLICT AROSE WHEN THE GIRLS
WERE GIVEN A FEW HOURS
OF FREE TIME.
Adrianne:
I JUST WANT TO GO SEE
JIM MORRISON'S GRAVE.
I WANT TO GO SHOPPING.
YOU GUYS WANT TO GO SHOPPING?
SO SHE'S GOING TO HAVE
TO COMPROMISE
AND GO SHOPPING WITH US,
AND WE'RE GOING TO HAVE
TO COMPROMISE
AND GO TO THE GRAVE WITH HER.
AND I SAID I WANT
TO GO SHOPPING.
YOU'RE NOT WILLING TO GO
TO JIM MORRISON'S GRAVE
FOR ADRIANNE?
THIS CONVERSATION CAN
GO ON ALL NIGHT.
BECAUSE YOU
WON'T COMPROMISE.
I DON'T GO SEE GRAVES,
JUST LIKE YOU DON'T
BELIEVE IN GOD,
I DON'T GO SEE GRAVES.
I DON'T TRY TO MAKE YOU
BELIEVE IN GOD, DO I?
SHE DOESN'T SEEM VERY
CHRIST-LIKE TO ME.
IN FACT, I THINK SHE SECRETLY
WORSHIPS THE DEVIL.
I WAS JUST TRYING TO KEEP IT
FROM BEING YOU AND ME
VERSUS THE TWO OF THEM,
BUT THAT'S (BLEEP) IT.
♪♪
Tyra: HAUTE COUTURE MEANS
HIGH FASHION IN FRENCH.
IT'S TAKEN VERY SERIOUSLY.
Adrianne:
THE GOWN IS LIKE A $20,000 GOWN.
THIS GOWN, LIKE MY BOOBS
ARE HANGING OUT THE SIDE
AND IN THE MIDDLE.
IT WAS JUST ENOUGH TO COVER
MY NIPPLE,
AND EVEN THAT PART WAS
SEE-THROUGH.
Tyra: FRENCH ARISTOCRATS
EVALUATED THE GIRLS
ON THEIR ABILITIES TO LIVE UP
TO THE GOWNS.
- HI.
- HELLO.
I'M ADRIAN,
NICE TO MEET YOU.
I'M SHANNON,
Robin:
IT REMINDED ME OF SOME,
LIKE CAT-DADDY TYPE OLD MEN,
LUSTING FOR YOUNG WOMEN.
Adrianne: ROBIN DIDN'T WANT
TO DO ANYTHING.
ROBIN WAS BEING A BITCH, BITCH,
BITCH, BITCH.
SHANNON'S JUST LIKE...
♪♪
WE CAME TO A POINT WHERE WE
HAVE TO MAKE A DECISION
ABOUT WHO'S GOING
TO BE THE WINNER.
AND THE PERSON WE RETAIN
IS ADRIANNE.
Tyra: ADRIANNE PROVED TO BE
THE LADY OF THE GROUP,
AND SHE CHOSE ELYSE
TO SHARE HER PRIZE...
A NIGHT IN THE LAP OF LUXURY
IN THE PRESIDENTIAL SUITE.
♪♪
DUDE,
THEY HAVE SET THIS UP
FOR OUR ROMANTIC NIGHT
TOGETHER, ELYSE.
♪♪
- GOOD NIGHT, SLUT HO.
- GOOD NIGHT.
Tyra:
THE NEXT DAY, THERE WAS
A REVEALING PHOTO SHOOT
AT THE BUDDHA BAR.
Jay: SO, YOU KNOW YOU'RE
MODELING DIAMONDS.
- COOL, RIGHT?
- YEAH.
OKAY, AND YOU'RE POSING NUDE.
(cricket chirping)
Tyra: ADRIANNE AND ELYSE
EMBRACED THE ASSIGNMENT.
♪♪
ROBIN AND SHANNON HAD
OTHER THOUGHTS.
I'M NOT GOING TO DO IT.
YOU'RE NOT
GOING TO DO IT?
YEAH, I DECIDED NOT TO.
I WAS TRYING TO IMAGINE
THE PICTURE IN MY HEAD,
WHAT I WOULD LOOK LIKE,
AND IT WOULD JUST NOT BE ME.
MY GRANDMOTHER USED
TO ALWAYS TELL ME,
"IF YOU DON'T STAND
FOR SOMETHING,
YOU'LL FALL FOR ANYTHING."
SO THIS STAND RIGHT HERE
I'M TAKING
MIGHT MAKE ME BE ELIMINATED,
SO MY TIME HERE IS UP,
THEN I'M OKAY WITH IT.
- MM-HMM.
- I'M OKAY WITH IT.
Tyra:
THE GIRLS RETURNED TO NEW YORK
AND FOUND THEMSELVES
IN A SITUATION
A LITTLE TOO CLOSE FOR COMFORT.
I REDUCED THE PENTHOUSE
TO ONE ROOM TO KEEP IT REAL.
CAN I SLEEP
IN KESSE'S BED?
YEAH, YOU HAVE TO.
I WAS JUST ASKING.
ROBIN, THERE'S NO ESCAPE.
EVIL HAS SURROUNDED US.
WELCOME HOME.
Tyra: AT THE ELIMINATION,
I CONFRONTED ROBIN
ABOUT INCONSISTENCIES
IN HER BEHAVIOR.
I SAW YOU OPEN THE DRESSING ROOM
AT THE COUTURE HOUSE,
AND YOU WERE NUDE,
AND YOU SHOOK YOUR CHEST AT JAY.
I SAW IT RIGHT THERE.
I WAS ON THE OTHER SIDE OF
THE CURTAIN-- YOU DIDN'T SEE ME.
I SAID, "MR. JAY.",
BECAUSE I SAW HIM RIGHT THERE
IN THE OPENING,
AND I SAID, "MR. JAY,"
LIKE THAT, AND THEN HE SAID...
(gasping) "RO..." HE LOOKED
LIKE, "ROBIN."
YOU DID IT LIKE THAT, ROBIN,
I WAS RIGHT THERE.
I'VE SEEN YOU PUT
YOUR BOOTY ON MR. JAY.
AND DO LIKE THAT.
NOTHING WRONG WITH IT,
IT'S ALL FUN.
OWN UP TO IT.
I'VE SEEN YOU BE IN A ROOM
AND DROP IT
LIKE IT'S HOT DOWN TO THE FLOOR
LIKE A STRIPPER.
NOTHING WRONG WITH IT.
IF YOU CALL IT DROPPING IT
LIKE IT'S HOT OR WHATEVER,
YOU CAN, BUT I MEAN,
I CAN SHOW YOU THE TAPES...
SHALL I DO IT FOR YOU?
- OH, I'D LIKE TO SEE IT.
- LET ME DROP IT.
(Janice) IF YOU'RE GONNA DO IT
I'M GONNA DO IT.
- DO WHAT?
- THIS.
ALL RIGHT!
IS THAT DROPPING IT
LIKE IT'S HOT, BABY?
MR. JAY, MR. JAY!
COME ON, MR. JAY!
IT'S CLEAR THAT ROBIN
DOESN'T HAVE
THE PERSONALITY
TO BE A TOP MODEL.
SHE SHOULD BE WORKING AT AVIS.
Tyra:
SHE HAD SUCH CONFIDENCE.
BUT THAT KIND OF BEHAVIOR
IS NOT SOMETHING
THAT I WANT TO PROMOTE
IN THIS INDUSTRY.
I DO THINK IT'S
A VERY IMPORTANT ISSUE
THAT SHE IS A FULL-FIGURED
BLACK WOMAN.
I THINK THAT'S A VERY
POWERFUL STATEMENT.
Tyra:
IN THE END,
ROBIN WAS ASKED TO LEAVE.
Robin:
I HAD THE CHANCE TO SHOW,
UM, A VARIATION OF BEAUTY.
IT'S TIME FOR ME TO MOVE ON.
MY JOB HERE IS DONE.
♪♪
Tyra:
ONLY THREE GIRLS REMAIN:
THE HIGH-FASHION
PRE-MED STUDENT...
THE ROCK AND ROLL TOMBOY...
AND THE ALL-AMERICAN VIRGIN.
FIND OUT WHO WILL BECOME
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL
WHEN THE SERIES FINALE STARTS
IN JUST A FEW MINUTES.
(giggling)
YOU SHUT UP.